I'm talking with Leia need is Kanellis
about an important new role he has right
across Europe give us an insight you've
got a challenging time ahead that's for
sure in fact I'm with incoming chair of
the body of European regulators for
electronic communications this body
advises the European Commission the
Parliament and the Council on several
issues which are related to the
implementation of new communication
technologies including Roland so we have
an office which is located in in Riga
Latvia and we have the heads of the 27
regulatory authorities across Europe we
meet regularly so as to tackle issues
which are related to the information
society and the European Digital Agenda
and of course [ __ ] I you must be a very
important part of that work that's for
sure we we try to boost investment while
safeguarding competition and FTTH is an
important technology so as to increase
the access speeds and allow every
citizen get innovative services from the
information society those services range
from electronic communication services
from high-speed video to social networks
and healthcare remote healthcare
applications so we we have a very
important role to play in the European
regulatory landscape sounds like an
enormous challenge what are you looking
forward to the most we're looking
forward to promoting investment while
safeguarding competition on the other
hand we would like to maintain a level
playing field between all operators in
the market and allow them meet the
objectives of the European digital
agenda in terms of coverage of the
European population and in terms of
reducing the digital divide between
rural and remote areas and the big
cities okay well we wish you every
success with it and thanks for sparing
is a few minutes to speak today thank
you very much Brian it's my president
that I'm looking forward to
to contribute to the achievement of the
goals of the European Digital Agenda and
by acting as business enablers in our
respect markets ftth connects the world
when are you getting connected ladies
and gentlemen welcome to Munich for the
ninth edition of the ftth conference
creating a brighter future